everyone
it's very good to be back here uh I I
gave a tutorial back in 2019 when the
world was a different place I'm glad
there's still a world to come back to
and give talks to so welcome everyone
um with these tutorials it's kind of
difficult because uh there's always a
mixed background right uh some of you
out there probably know some statistics
and some machine learning and some
Python and different combinations of
both so I'm not going to make any
assumptions about your background
knowledge here this is meant to be a
kind of a high level overview of
Bayesian statistics probabilistic
programming and Pie MC
so we won't go in depth into anything
this is kind of just a taste and there's
lots and lots of resources out there for
you if you want to dig a little bit
deeper
um as Mateo mentioned I work for the
Philadelphia Phillies which is a
baseball team in the United States we
are hiring by the way we get a good
office view
unless you don't like baseball in which
case it's kind of an obnoxious view
um software developers quantitative
analysts data engineers
if you can throw baseball 100 miles an
hour relief pitchers we're also looking
for so let me know
um
so probabilistic programming isn't
really a new thing the the term is kind
of new
um and uh when we talk about a
probabilistic program we're really
talking about any computer program whose
output is non-deterministic or it's
partially determined based on the
outcomes of random numbers and so
um
really it can be you can do PP in any
language that has a random number
generator but of course
um you know some choices of language
language are better than than others um
and what we're really specifically
talking about here essentially is a
language where there are additional
Primitives right so we're used to
Primitives in the sense of integers and
floats and strings a probabilistic
programming has Primitives that are
stochastic so uh objects that Generate
random numbers have stochastic
properties
particularly from you know known
statistical distributions normal
distributions binomials things like that
uh so you know you can you could have an
object that is a normal distribution you
can draw 100 random values from that uh
you can it can get
um more sophisticated than that there
are distributions over entire functions
like a gaussian process where you can
draw a function from a distribution or
distribution over functions and make
predictions on that and then importantly
you can condition one based on the other
right so you can have a variable that's
drawn from one distribution and then use
that draw to condition the draw of
another random variable so what this
does is it allows us to specify
statistical models probability models at
a very high level right it's all about
abstracting away a lot of this stuff and
the main reason we do probabilistic
programming is to facilitate Bayesian
inference
and Beijing inference is probably
different than the statistics you may
have learned at University although
newer programs are incorporating this
stuff a little bit more why should we do
what is first first of all what having
said I'd make no assumptions what is
Bayesian inference what is Bayesian
statistics this is Andrew Gilman uh
Andrew gellman's definition and he's a
prominent Bayesian out of Columbia
University he says practical methods for
making inferences from data using
probability models for quantities we
observe and about which we wish to learn
so the idea is you build a model using
probability distribution everything
that you are interested in has a
probability distribution associated with
it and the probabilities that we're
talking about here are a little bit
backwards from what you might be used to
so and in fact Bayesian inference used
to be called inverse probability because
what we're going to do is we're going to
infer from effects to cause
so y here is some data that you observed
Theta is uh our unknown quantities
random variables predictions whatever
you're interested in and you're going to
observe something about the world and
we're going to use that to infer
something about the things you're
interested in right
so it's these conditioning statements
that help determine what the causes
might be
um
why why would we want to do this uh this
is again a definition from Lincoln
Barker's book on Bayesian statistics
it's attractive because it's useful
um you know there are sort of
philosophical approach reasons that you
might want to be Beijing rather than
frequentists but um it's it's very
useful and it's very simple to at least
uh conceptually it's very simple uh all
the pieces are very simple but it can be
used to build something large and
complex and interesting so it's it's a
utility really that motivates me
here's the requisite showing of The
Bayes formula right so this is what
we're doing here
um
we're going to use probability
distributions to characterize what we
know and don't know about the stuff
we're interested in again and again
Theta here are the things we're
interested in could be one variable
could be a hundred variables would be an
entire model
and so the idea is you you have some
some uh information about the world
before you start doing your experiment
or your project and and that's we
encapsulate that in a prior this is what
we know before seeing the data and then
we have some observations some data
that we uh encapsulate as a statistical
likelihood and we use that the magic of
Base formula is that it it we use that
to update our information about Theta
and give us that inverse probability
that I talked about before so after
having observed something what what can
I say
about about Theta
and this so this is really just a rule
for learning from data and that's really
what machine learning is trying to do
all the time
so um in probabilistic programming we
want to come up with a a program that
does this for us because that's kind of
the hard part in Bayesian inference is
the actual calculation of that posterior
distribution
and in a stochastic program what we're
doing is we're specifying most of the
right hand side of that equation so
we're going to give it information about
our prior we're going to get information
about the data
and you model this kind of joint
distribution of your data and your
unknowns
so let's look at these pieces a little
bit so prior distributions
um
again we're trying to quantify the
uncertainty in the latent variables
before we've we've seen the day we may
not know much about it so we you know
everything has to be given a
distribution in base so we might give it
a normal distribution which is you know
your bell curve maybe a mean of zero and
a standard deviation of one
it says that we know essentially it's
somewhere between negative four and four
perhaps
um
this is also a normal distribution that
line across the bottom
uh so normal with mean zero but a
standard deviation of 100 so variance of
ten thousand it's essentially a straight
line in this region and that means we
don't know very much about it right it's
diffuse it's uninformative largely
uninformative
um often we know something about the
system we're studying right so let's say
something like I don't know an
infectious disease that ravages the
world uh its prevalence is going to be
low even during a pandemic right so a
beta distribution describes things
between zero and one so a rate can be
either be anything between non-existent
to everywhere zero and one and even even
a prevalent disease is going to be you
know 10 or less most of the time
so that's a beta 150. so this is again
characterizing what we know ahead of
time
then we have the likelihood the other
piece that we're responsible for
specifying how does the data relate to
the model is that so now we're
conditioning on our model
uh conditioning your model on on The
observed on The observed data and our
data can look a lot of different ways
right so our data is often normally
distributed right Heights and weights of
people
uh any sums of other variables tend to
be normal because of something called
the central limit theorem uh so what we
observe X sorry I switched it from y to
x x here it could be normal with some
unknown uh mu and and and variants that
we need to estimate
uh baseball uh right so we have hitters
that try to hit the ball uh in a certain
number of tries so we want to estimate
the probability that this uh hitter
might get a a hit in the sometime in the
future so we're gonna use a binomial
distribution to describe that sort of
data successes out of a certain number
of Trials
let's say you run a website and you're
trying to estimate you know expected
numbers of visitors per month there are
likelihoods for uh estimate for
characterizing counts of things right
when that could be you know up in the
tens or hundreds of thousands
right
and so the magic of Bayes is that it's
going to take those
two pieces of information what we know
before some new information and generate
something afterwards and that so that
funny little symbol in between uh the
two sides of the equation means
proportional to means equal to up to uh
but not including a constant value
and so full Bays looks like that
and the the thing that makes bass hard
is is essentially the the probability of
Y underneath uh in the denominator of
that fraction in Bayes formula that is a
kind of a weird thing probability y
probability of the data it's actually
the marginal probability of the data so
it's it's the numerator integrated
over all of the thetas
and uh
you know I I took calculus in school I
can do integration when there's like one
variable uh I think I took a test where
I had to do twice two variables
multivariate integration is very very
hard and nearly impossible and and
particularly in models where you have
hundreds of thousands of parameters that
you have to integrate over so it
requires numerical methods in order to
do it and that's what probabilistic
programming is going to do for us is
it's going to take that inference
procedure that's usually very complex
and tricky and uh and kind of make it go
away
but uh you know like I like to do and
when I teach this in a course it you can
do it by hand for simple problems and I
think it's useful even in a situation
like this to do this together so we'll
do a simple Problem by hand and then
we'll look at Pine seat
uh
so let I'm going to use again a baseball
example because I have lots of baseball
data so uh I'm going to estimate so
uh for those of you unfamiliar with the
sport the pitcher throws the ball the
batter's got to try to hit it and it's
very hard to hit a baseball when it's
thrown at you at high rate of speed and
so they strike out some of the time so
strikeout is when you take three swings
at the ball and you miss and then you're
you're done and then the next batter
comes up and so if we're trying to
minimize the uh strikeout rate of a
ladder if we're running a baseball team
so we have a player on the Phillies name
Nick Castellanos he plays right field
and um back in 2019
um he he came up to about 22 times to
start the season and he only had one
strikeout which is really low
but of course you know
22 plate appearances and all that much
you'll probably have 600 of those during
the year so we want to know what we want
to know is what's his true strikeout
right what's the underlying truth there
because you could get that by accident
um
so the reason we can do this one by hand
is uh a little trick a little
statistical trick called conjugacy and
for certain data for certain models with
certain types of variables you can do
the
base formula update without having to do
any integration and in this case you can
because
that strikeout data remember is binomial
right it's the number how many 22 tries
and he did it once so that's binomial
data if you put a beta prior on that and
we saw the beta prior for the disease
thing right it's values between zero one
we're estimating a rate of strikeouts
here we're going to call that a beta
distribution and turns out if you
combine the two of those you get a
posterior distribution that's also a
beta so that's pretty handy right
because you can estimate that and then
maybe observe some more data and take
the posterior that's a beta distribution
and make it the prior the next time and
look at some more data and you can keep
turning the Bayesian Crank That Way
and so this is what it looks like a
little bit of math here not too much
this is what a binomial distribution
looks like so Theta is our probability
of the Event Y or the number of events
right and if I just look at the what are
called kernel of this distribution it's
Theta little y one minus Theta the N
minus y so the number of successes and
the numbers of failures and their
Associated probabilities well a beta
distribution looks like this
and if you squinted those they look
really similar don't they Theta to the
something one minus Theta to the
something in this case the variable of
interest is Theta up there the variable
of interest is y but they're the same
form so you can squish those together
and reduce it and you end up with
another beta distribution and beta
distribution is parametrized by Alpha
and beta essentially the number of Prior
successes and prior failures
and so it's beta Alpha plus the number
of observed successes beta Alpha plus
the number of observed successes in beta
plus the number of failures n minus y
so let's do it let's do some bass so
this is what one of 22 looks like in
terms of a likelihood right and it
implies you know a strikeout rate that's
below 10 percent although it could be as
high as you know 30 percent and you know
it just kind of happened by accident
we're not sure
well let's uh get a a prior for this
well how do we get a prior for this
what's our prior what I did for a prior
is I went to my big baseball database
and I pulled out all of the batting data
over three years of of uh three seasons
of playing and I I took out all the
players with over 200 played appearances
so lots of data and I got their
strikeout rate and in scipy there's a
big stats library in scipy and you can
just fit distributions whichever one you
want any distribution you call in this
case beta because it's a beta
distribution dot fit and it'll give you
the parameter estimates and that turns
out it's a beta 1035.
right
so we can we've got the formulas to do
both and so uh the black line over there
is our prior
um the the uh
or sorry that's the data the prior is
the dark blue line and then the
posterior is always going to be
somewhere between the prior and the
likelihood right uh it's a little bit
closer to the to the prior in this case
because there wasn't much data and now
we have kind of a reasonable posterior
estimate right
uh we didn't have to choose that prior
we could choose a different one
um you know what if we know a little bit
more about baseball it's like oh
castianos is a right fielder different
players in different positions have
different characteristics so I'm just
going to take the right fielders in my
data set more restricted data set data
set to use and that turns out to be a
beta 1547.
okay and that
that corresponds to the red here so now
we're you know we're hedging our bets a
little bit more back towards the prior
of a higher strikeout rate because
outfielders are big Heavy Hitters that
strike out a lot
um right which one is right
we're not sure
um but the point is you can choose your
prior based on on whatever information
you have and you really want to bring as
much information as you can to the table
to get the best estimate the goal here
is to get the right answer not to be
statistically pure right as long as you
tell people what your prior is as long
as you specify it as part of your model
you can argue later about whether or not
that was a good choice or not
okay that's the idea that's kind of your
base by hand
but um you know
it uh your your model and your data will
quickly outstrip what you're able to do
by hand and you'll have to turn to some
software to help you out for bigger
models and here in 2022 uh we're
Extremely Blessed uh with a lot of
different
um
choices when it comes to doing Bays even
just in Python these are just the ones
for doing this in Python right so Pi
Stan and Pi MC
pyro numpyro kind of the Facebook thing
tensorflow probability if you're a
Google guy uh
and and others there's a whole there's I
just want to give you a subset here
okay
um we'll talk about here about uh Pi MC
uh because I work on that project
um
so Pi MC is just for fitting Bayesian
statistical models uh using a variety of
methods there are more than one method
for doing Bayesian inference something
called Markov chain Monte Carlo is
primarily what we use and I'm going to
describe describe that in a little bit
of detail later it includes all those
statistical distributions you'll need
that's kind of one of the things that it
takes a little bit time to learn to kind
of use Bayesian methods is learning all
the different statistical distributions
and when and where they should be used
it leverages a package called RVs which
kind of spun out of python of pine C
years ago for doing lots of output
analysis and plotting it's very
extensible so if you find a probability
distribution that we don't have it's
easy to implement your own you can
extend even the uh algorithms for
fitting the models if you're so disposed
and that includes things like
non-parametric Bayesian methods which is
another great aspect of Base that we
don't have time to go into today
and we just released a new version Prime
C4 was released just a couple of weeks
ago we're very excited about that uh it
has now GPU support uh and supports
different computational backends like
Jax and number
a lot more user friendly than before and
and generally runs faster so all the
things you like to see in new versions
of software so I encourage you to try it
out we'll use it here in our examples
okay
um I'm going to switch now to uh
uh Jupiter notebook
if I can find my way around my own
computer
feel free to interrupt with questions by
the way if anybody has one has them I
will uh I can answer them while I'm
switching
yes
the question was among the different
libraries are there differences between
what each of them has to offer
um
I would say that the differences are
mainly in terms of High versus low level
you know Stan is probably the the market
leader if you like and it's it's very
it's it's it's a little bit lower level
than Pi MC
and it's built really just to do Markov
chain Monte Carlo really quickly
um so and it tends to be look a little
bit more like R than python so it
depends on kind of the interfaces that
you like to use
um but um you know most of the main ones
you know pyro pie torch they're they're
all going to be used and and some of
them have uh Place emphasis on different
methods for fitting Bayesian models so
numpyro pyro are tend to be more towards
the variational inference side which is
a for bigger data sets
um so uh so that kind of reflects that
choice as well but they all generally do
the same thing a lot they allow you to
fit your model at kind of a high level
where you don't need to know necessarily
very much about the fitting alge rhythms
and then generate results for you
okay
yes go ahead
um
well there's not too much to say about
the likelihood right so it's a
likelihood is really just another
probability distribution
the only thing is is that it's it's and
we'll see this in a second it's it's
pinned to your observation so they don't
change
when you run the model it's kind of used
to inform the rest of the model
so uh mechanistically in terms of how
you specify your model there's really no
difference between uh your likelihoods
and your priors
um it's really just that the the your
likelihoods have data associated with
them you can draw new values from that
distribution but they're just normal
distributions binomial distributions Etc
which is
the methodology
one over
uh model selection so what part of
there's really three big steps to doing
Bayesian inference one is write your
model down you know specify all your
probability distributions whichever
choice you want to make
fit the model which is what this talk is
mostly concerned with and then the third
is model checking and it's a very
important step and that's where you go
in and you see whether your model fits
the data and if you've made a bad choice
of Prior likelihood that should show up
in kind of bad goodness of fit tests
yeah
it's funny that you ask about the
likelihood most people are worried about
the prior you're worried about the
likelihood that's great because they're
equally important
okay so I'm going to quickly run through
how to fit some models in pi MC here
um
uh
we are going to use more bait another
baseball example to motivate this
um so this is uh
hopefully my import data Imports will
run
in finite time here
oh
all right I'll talk while it's doing
that makes me nervous that it's uh
running this long just to import anyway
um
so this is the stocky sticky stuff
incident uh so last year uh baseball
started cracking down on pitchers
putting stuff on their baseballs and why
would they do that
um well pitchers try to get a good grip
on their ball on the ball and uh and
spin it so that it'll create General
generate some movement the movement
makes it harder to hit it's a way that's
been doing this in way as far back as
baseball goes which is well over 100
years putting stuff like pine tar and uh
mixtures of uh of rosin and sunscreen
anything to make it kind of tacky and
sticky and this caused a lot more
strikeouts which aren't as fun for
spectators to watch and so even though
the rule was kind of in the rule books
they started cracking down in kind of
the middle of last year and you'd get
you know a 10 game suspension and a fine
and things like that and you know just
to give you an idea uh this is what a
this is why they do it so this is one of
our pitchers Aaron Nola throwing a
curveball and you'll see
right at the end it kind of dips and
it's because he spins the ball really
quickly and
it makes it really hard to hit
so they started cracking down you know
very invasive checks unbuckling their
belts checking the insides of their
gloves nobody was very happy about this
and um
and so what we're going to try to do
here is try to estimate whether or not
the
sticky stuff Crackdown had an effect on
the spin rates of baseball so we we
collect a ton of data now Major League
Baseball does every game generates six
to seven terabytes of data because they
monitor all the players on the field the
ball the movement of the ball and it's
actually all available for free on the
MLB Advanced media website a statcast
website and so I I downloaded
um
all of the data from 2021 the year where
they cracked down and looked at their
spin rates so this is what the data
looks like
um
we can plot it so here's the spin rates
by date
a little Gap in the middle as they take
a break in July to do the All-Star game
so there's no games for a little bit
under a week but otherwise continue
these are all the pitches and the spin
rates on each so on average there's
about
2500 rpm that's the spin rate of the
ball with lots of variation
and so what we're interested in knowing
here is is there a change during the
season in spin rate due to the Crackdown
trying to avoid getting suspended
um and does that
change Point uh correspond to when the
Crackdown happened which was uh
say here
June 3rd is when the information kind of
leaked out that they were going to crack
down
so let's build a model for this what is
the model going to look like here I'm
going to extract some data all I need is
the date and the spin rate so that's
what these two lines is doing
and so the model I'm going to use here
is a change Point model
um it's a relatively simple model just
to demonstrate how to use Pi MC and so
the idea here is that really the
simplest possible model is to have a
constant spent mean spin rate across the
league
and at some point there'd be a change
due to this change in policy so there'd
be an early and a late spin rate so what
we statisticians would call a piecewise
constant model right two pieces and so
mu 1 and mu 2 are the two rates tau is
going to be our change point and the
tricky part here is that tau's not known
I mean we have a guess at what it was if
our hypothesis is true but we really
don't know what it is and and that's the
nice thing in Bays is that anything you
don't know you just put probability
distribution around it and you estimated
included in your model and so that's
what we're going to do here
so two Muse and a Tau are our variables
and then we'll have two likelihoods and
these are going to be normally
distributed distributed
um
with the two means and then some common
Sigma maybe the variance changed
afterwards as well we're just doing a
simple I'm not saying this is a good
model this is just a simple model and
and somewhat reasonable uh given what
we're trying to do
okay so let's step through building this
in Pine C so we're
really there are two different types of
objects in an abasian model stochastic
and deterministic variables so mu 1 mu2
the means and the change Point Tau are
all random variables we don't know what
they are oh and sigma the kind of noise
distribution of noise around the mean
um so there Aris they arise from a
physical random process that uh sorry
they're random in the sense that we
don't know them so that we don't think
that the underlying mean necessarily is
changing except in a way that we include
in our model but we're using probability
distributions to characterize our
information State about that variable
all right so it's an epistemic
Randomness here not necessarily a one
that's stochastic
um and it's representing our uncertainty
about these values
uh there are other objects that are
deterministic so given in a given year
the rate uh is completely determined by
mu and mu 1 and mu 2 and Tau right if
it's on one side of Tau or the other
um so the the vector of rates for every
day of baseball is going to be
deterministic given those random
variables right so we have stochastic
things and deterministic things
all right so
um here's the rest of our what choices
are we going to give for our probability
distributions well our means are going
to be normal with mean 2500 because that
was I peaked at the mean there um and
then a you know a standard deviation of
100 which is a variance of ten thousand
so way bigger than we need uh uh Tau
I'll just say uniform between zero and T
being the last day of the season and
then a half normal distribution for
Cigna it's half normal because variances
have to be positive right kind of have
negative variance so we just chop the
negative side off of the normal
distribution
uh and Pie MC it looks like this
so
um
a couple of things to note here uh the
with statement we use a with statement
which uh in Python is a context manager
and context Managers generally are used
for things like network connections file
opening and closing and it kind of
manages all that for you here we're
going to use it to open and close a
model and add variables to it so it's a
nice little trick that makes models easy
to specify so we're going to create a
model object which is really just a big
container for our variables and how
they're related to one another we're
going to call it spin rate model and
then here are our two of our priors so
here's mu and mu here has shape of two
because there's the early and the late
and then there's the uniform
distribution right with a lower and an
upper bound that I'm using just you know
the first and the last day of the Season
which I've encoded as integers from zero
to Big T
does that make sense
okay notice each distribution has a name
it's got a label essentially and it's
been added added to the model okay
um
and in fact you can't even specify you
can't even use these random variables
outside of a model if I just say I want
a normal called x with mean mu 0 and
sigma 10 and I try to run it I get an
error I get an index error but if you
scroll down to the bottom it says no
model on context stack which is needed
to instantiate distributions okay so the
it's got a lot of overhead associated
with it that's that's used for
integrating that distribution into the
model
and under the hood
oops
oh I changed the names of these things
so change this to Mu
under the hood
all of these variables are things called
tensor variables inside the asara
library asara is the um essentially the
back end for pi MC that does all of the
heavy lifting uh particularly building
the kind of model graph it was it is
based on thiano which is a uh now
extinct deep learning library
uh and we thanks to the efforts of uh
Brandon Willard and others in the asara
team basically co-opted that package uh
at that library and and turned it
essentially into a probabilistic
programming engine uh that allows us to
compile it to different back ends so
you're going to see a lot of mention of
asara that's really just kind of the
back end of Pi MC
okay
um all the distributions that you're
seeing here are based on our subclasses
of a distribution superclass uh in in
particular The Continuous subclass and
so every distribution really all it
needs to have is a method for returning
the log probability that's what we use
to fit the model
optionally a random method for drawing
new random values doesn't have to have
that but if you want to sample from your
model you'll want to include that as
well so if you're implementing your own
distributions that's roughly how it how
it looks
um so for any of these variables for
example Tau we can pass it you know a
value of 5 and of and uh get the log
probability back right so that's the log
probability of of a five you know day
five of the uh season essentially
similarly random is in uh you use that
via the draw function
right so we're going to draw five values
of mu remember mu is of size two there's
two means so it's drawing five sets of
two in this case right
if you do want to use our statistical
distributions outside of a pie MC model
you can do that there's a class method
called dist that just pulls out the
statistical distribution so here I
created a normal called X of size 1000
and then I
generate a histogram of that right so
you can use them outside of Pi C you've
just got to extract it in the
appropriate way
and pipe C has a ton of distributions
there's the whole list
right so chances are what you need is in
here and if it isn't I've just showed
you how to essentially how to do it okay
every distribution has a shape
remember mu is of size two so there's
this is a univariate distribution but
it's kind of a batch of two of them
right it's not a multivariate normal
although it could be
um but you can have kind of batches of
distributions like this okay let's keep
going here so
the nice thing about the context manager
is that you can you know add some
variables close it up crack it open
again add a few more so we're going to
add Sigma here because we had one more
random variable this is our our
observation noise essentially and the
models keeping track of what's in it and
and you know all the details so there's
those are the variables we've added so
far
um
and uh Pine sees doing a lot of stuff
under the hood for you here
um you know
um for example when you specify a half
normal distribution as I said before
it's constrained to be positive but when
we're doing s model estimation and we're
doing mcmc sampling we don't want to
have to worry about that lower bound of
zero and so everything under the hood
gets transformed to the real line so in
this case we're going to log transform
it uh so you know you pass a negative 1
to this
I don't know why this is taking so long
uh you get it's undefined it's undefined
at in negative values and if you look
under the hood here
you'll see that the name implies that
Something's Happened Sigma underscore
log so it's been log transformed
um but you don't have to worry about
that they inverse transform it when you
get the results of the model so you
don't have to it's really just something
that's convenient for for computation
all right now deterministic variable so
deterministic variable again is is
anything that's completely determined by
the value of its parents so our Vector
of rates
across the season is completely
determined by mu and Tau and so this is
it here it's a little switch statement
when tau is greater than day in so
past the the switch point uh
it's mu zero sorry if Tau if it's the
other way around if tau is greater than
Day N so it's the first half of the
Season uh it's mu zero otherwise it's mu
1.
and notice here that um I didn't give
this a name like I did with the other
things you know it was a normal mu and
then uniform Tau this is kind of an
anonymous thing here with no name
associated with it because this is sort
of an intermediate calculation I'm not
really interested in this Vector of
copied values essentially and so this in
this sense they'll kind of be thrown
away at the end of the model fitting
exercise
if you want to specify something as
uh some bad color choices here if you
want to specify something as
if you want to make it persist in the
model and summarize it at the end you
have to wrap it in a pine C
deterministic object and then you give
it a name
okay so now this will exist in the trace
that you get out the other end otherwise
you can just leave it anonymously
and of course the shape on this is going
to be bigger
because we are
so there's one for every pitch that's
thrown here yep 7791.
all right last step the likelihood
so as I said before there's really no
difference between stochastic and
observed variables in the model one just
has data associated with it the others
don't and so the way that you do that in
Prime C is you pass the data to the
distribution using the observed
argument here so spin radar is the
vector of spin rates for every pitch
otherwise it's just a regular normal
distribution
and so mu is R so it's our Vector of
rates
and then Sigma is the observation noise
okay and you can always see what your
likelihoods are oops haven't haven't run
the cell yet there it is
okay you can always check in what it is
looking at observed RVs
and then another step that's useful at
the end is to actually look at your
model and so you can generate a graph a
picture of the graph using graphviz this
is always good right if you're building
more complex models I often do this and
I'll have like a node floating around
unattached to anything and that would
cause problems so just make sure that
your models all connected the way you
you think it should be
okay and then now uh we run this and all
we have to do is call sample
all right
um and I anticipate this to take longer
than it should because something's weird
with my computer today so this is the uh
the magic inference button this is a
phrase coined by Thomas Vicky who's here
in this uh
meeting he allowed me to say he's
trademarked it uh but he let me say it
uh and so well this is the thing I
didn't give it any arguments just to
show you how easy it can be so there are
a lot of
defaults implied here and we'll go into
that in the next kind of the next
section and so it will run this in just
a few seconds
yeah should take way less time than this
sorry about that it took about two
seconds the other day
um so anyway you'll see what it says
here Auto assigning not sampler we don't
know what that is yet initializing nuts
using something and then multi-process
sampling it's going to sample four
chains and it shows you the random
variables that it's estimating and then
it's it's running
it was about 10 times as long as it
usually takes okay and then we can
generate plots of things so
um one we're interested in here is Tau
so the mean of tau is 68 although it's
got a weird bimodal thing it's maybe a
little uncertain about where that is the
mean is 68 and if you look at where in
the calendar 68 is it's June the 8th
Which is less than a week after they
changed the regulation so there's a
little bit of evidence here of change
spin rates changing okay
all right uh
next I'm going to dig into a little bit
more into
um
mcmc so I need to
unmirror my monitor
yes please ask a question while I'm
oh yeah yeah we're definitely interested
in how big it is let me see yep
um so oh you can't see this anymore
um
mu naught was
2539 and mu 1 was 2442. so about a
hundred RPMs less which can make the
difference
it's a game of fine margins
uh
all right
go for it
uh well once once it's compiled it's
kind of out of pine sees hands so the so
the the Jax is so it compiles to C which
is what theiano gave us before Jax and
then uh a little bit of number at the
moment and so potentially more than that
um and all it's doing is compiling it
for the mcmc computation so all the
features are aren't really relevant it's
just doing the gradient calculation and
all of the kind of mcmc steps
all right so we're going to talk about
mcmc this is the um
so the main challenge in doing in
fitting Bayesian models resides in
actually calculating the joint posterior
distribution over all of the models
right and so so this was the hard piece
right integration is hard
now if I was teaching my course here at
Vanderbilt I would spend like two weeks
going through from the basic this is
kind of ranked in order of complexity
all the different ways you can
approximate a posterior distribution
from simple but probably inadequate to
getting closer and closer to something
that's usable
right we're going to skip ahead to the
Workhorse this is kind of the de facto
standard method now for fitting Bayesian
model so mcmc stands for Markov chain
Monte Carlo
so two pieces to that Monte Carlo and
Markov chain
um so it's going to simulate a Markov
chains so Monte Carlo is just a fancy
word for simulation using a random
number generator and
um we're going to simulate a Markov
chain uh where the function of Interest
are posterior distribution is its unique
invariant stationary distribution lots
of jargon there first jargon we're going
to break here is what a Markov chain is
so um Markov chain is something called a
stochastic process which is just jargon
for a indexed set of random variables so
it's typically indexed by T because it's
often temporal but doesn't have to be
and it's markovian so the markovian
condition is
it's all it says is that the probability
of some variable its value in the next
time step given its current value
the last value all the way back to its
initial value is the same as the
probability of its next value given just
its current value
so essentially the history doesn't
matter other than right now right these
are pretty common like we play Monopoly
that's a Markov chain right you Landing
in Park Place in the next turn only
is only determined by the fact that
you're I don't know on reading Railway
and not that you were in jail three
turns ago or anything like that the
current state matters the past doesn't
matter so it's kind of mild
non-independence if you want to think of
it that way
it's very hard to estimate Bayesian
models by drawing independent samples so
what we resort to are dependent samples
and we can get the same sort of result
it can't just be any Markov chain that
we simulate here though it's going to be
a special one the specialness comes from
a property called the detailed balance
equation we want a Markov chain that
obeys this property and this has to do
with balancing movement to and from
different states
okay glossing over lots of complexity
here but I just wanted to give you a
little bit of intuition about what's
going on here if it obeys this property
then Pi is the limiting distribution of
the chain I.E the posterior distribution
so Pi of Pi of Y Pi of X is going to be
our posterior distribution so anytime
you see a new mcmc algorithm pop up the
paper will show that it's reversible
that's kind of the proof the thing that
you have to prove before anybody
believes you
the very simplest mcmc out so there's no
such thing as mcmc as an algorithm it's
a class of algorithm right it's like
bird there's no birds called a bird
they've all got species associated with
them same thing here so one of the
simplest ones is the Metropolis
algorithm and it's really easy a couple
steps here that last one should be a
four not a one don't know why that
happened so four steps all right you
initialize all the parameters of your
model to arbitrary values and then you
have another distribution that's easy to
sample with from and you draw potential
new values for that distribution
you evaluate whether it's good or not
and whether it's good or not depends on
the ratio of the posterior log posterior
distribution under the new values Theta
Prime over its current values
okay you can't calc you can't you don't
really know what this posterior
distribution is but you can always
remember every variable has a log p in
Prime C you can always calculate the log
probability for any value so you can
always do this
you have this acceptance probability if
that probability is higher than that one
you accept it all the time and if you
don't you accept it probabilistically
you draw a uniform random variable and
you kind of flip a coin so you sometimes
accept bad values right it's part of
this reversibility thing you don't just
want to find the peak of the
distribution you want to find the whole
thing and so Metropolis sampling kind of
looks like this
right so it's proposing values
sometimes accepting them
I can't remember who I stole this from
it was probably Thomas did I steal this
from you Thomas
no okay then I did it this is mine
um
and but notice it's getting stuck here
so this is a complex problem this is
actually a thousand-dimensional
multivariate normal so it's not complex
sorry it's very simple it's just large
right it's a big geometry and so it's
kind of getting stuck it's not doing a
very good job here
interesting well the reason it's getting
stuck is it's not very good
Metropolis algorithm is not very good
it's very easy to implement it's very
general but it doesn't do well for
larger models and the reason is is that
as models get big the volume in terms of
the space of the parameter space grows
exponentially so that exponential line
is the volume the probability or the
density
the probability density function is
there so as you move away
from the mode the volume gets very big
and the density doesn't so most of the
probability is actually away from the
mode
and so it's really easy to get stuck in
areas of low probability
this area of high probability it's hard
to see that there was shaded it's called
the typical set and that's what we want
to do is estimate the typical set
and to do that we need a better
algorithm and the better algorithm is
something called hamiltonian Monte Carlo
hamiltonian Monte Carlo is yet another
mcmc algorithm but this one uses more
information about your model
specifically it uses gradient
information
so Metropolis we're doing a random walk
right we were randomly drawing a new
value and as you might sort of
intuitively that's not very efficient
right just random values are they going
to be good or not probably not but if we
use information about the gradient we
can get essentially better suggested
values and do a better job and so what
this does is it simulates kind of a
physical analogy of of a particle moving
you think about a skateboard or in a
skate park right and you kind of you
know push your skateboarder into the
park and what is what does she do she
kind of rolls around following the
topology of of the park right or or a
marble in a salad bowl or something like
that right goes up and down and so we do
this to explore the posterior
distribution and so we add an auxiliary
variable to simulate essentially
well position and momentum or kinetic
energy and potential energy right and
and uh in kind of discrete time
discretized time
okay and so it requires the gradient and
so derivatives derivatives are easy
nowadays on computers integration is
hard just
um derivatives are easy
particularly when you have a package
like thiano or asara or tensorflow or Pi
torch whatever they'll give you these
things for free now so we calculate
essentially the changes in position and
the changes in momentum
um and use that to monitor uh where the
where to go in terms of characterizing
the typical set of the distribution so
you take all of these little LeapFrog
steps you're kind of following the
Contours of the posterior distribution
you stop you take a value and then you
you know flick the particle in a
different random Direction
and so the algorithm is even even easier
than Metropolis sample a new velocity
from a univariate gaussian I.E or
initial
energy perform a certain number of Leap
Frog steps to get a new state because
you're simulating you're using it's a
continuous system but you're using
discrete steps to approximate it and
then you do an accept reject move
because you're doing this approximation
at the end and you accept it or not
and hamiltonian MC looks like this
boom
and it can even do more complicated
things than multivariate normals it can
you know be those weird banana shaped
distributions with a huge Ridge on it or
whatever okay
in fact that logo at the very beginning
one of our developers Colin uh Carol did
simulating the pine C logo so it can be
super complex stuff okay and then I'll
skip right to the punch line is that you
know when you saw remember when I ran
sample it said initializing nuts well
nuts is a
uh particular tuned auto-tuning version
of hamiltonian Monte Carlo called the no
u-turn sampler it's no u-turn because
when you know when you do that
moving around the space what happens
when you go up a hill and you reach the
top of the hill
you roll backwards again and you want to
stop before you do that U-turn because
you're just you know recalculating the
same values over and over again so the
no u-turn sample sampler is the state of
the art
and this is why we use it so this is the
same
10 000 dimensional or a thousand
dimensional multivari normal just
marginal two variables from that and
that's what Metropolis does
another mcmc sampler that nobody uses
anymore and that's what nuts does
relative to just independent draws right
so that's what we want to do and that's
why we use nuts
okay that's your you know this this
few minutes of Talk would have taken
like a week yeah in my class so we've
glossed over a lot of stuff but um
hopefully that gives you a little bit of
of intuition
is there a question while I'm
moving back over
yes
you don't and that's why you want a auto
tuning algorithm that's what nuts does
is it it optimizes the number of
LeapFrog steps it depends on the model
right simpler models you you want to you
want to do as few as possible the goal
isn't to perfectly follow the path it's
to get a good point and as you can
imagine the more steps you have to take
the more computationally intensive it is
so you want to take as few as possible
and so the nuts algorithm estimates the
optimal number for you yeah good
question
and I wish I could
mirror this thing again ah there we go
all right
let's see it's 11 54. I started out I
have a half an hour still is that right
cool
we may even have time for questions
although we're taking questions during
it so
any any more questions by the way since
we're
on schedule
sorry I didn't understand that sorry can
you repeat it again
yes what's your have you done in the
Hamilton a month ago but will you put it
on the left side of the equation to the
right
the topology of Bureau Park what is it
um it's determined automatically so so
there's two things there's two
components so the position is your
actual posterior distribution that
you're interested in uh and the momentum
is the auxiliary variable that you're
giving with this with the energy so so
your model your posterior distribution
is the position so it's not using
kinetic energy potential energy it's
using position and momentum
and so the momentum is auxiliary it gets
thrown away and you keep the position
all right let's dig into this a little
bit here
um so we're going to use another Sports
example but I'll at least use a sport
that most of you are probably familiar
with
so Six Nations rugby
uh it's the pre the premier European
rugby competition those are the only six
countries that play rugby I guess you
could argue whether Italy plays it or
not but they participate
and um so we're gonna this example's on
a version of this is on our website as
one of the examples so what we're doing
is we're taking historical rugby data to
try to predict the outcome of the next
tournament right and I you know it's
probably not valid because we're using
you know results from 2014. probably
entirely different players on all of
these teams by now uh but forget that
for the moment and so we're going to
take a whole bunch of historical scores
and try to predict new scores I'm going
to do that by estimating latent
variables which is what Bayesian
inference is good for and the latent
variables will be the strengths the
underlying unobserved strengths of these
teams in terms of scoring and preventing
uh
uh points from being scored
right
so this is all the data a home score and
an away score for every game going back
to 2014.
so our model here will look a little
different so again you got to think
about our unknown variables and our
likelihoods and so forth uh let's in
this case start with the likelihood work
backwards so
scoring points they're discrete you
can't score half points you can't score
negative points so a poisson is a
reasonable approach here poisson
distribution is accounting distribution
has to be positive the mean and the
variance are equal so as as the numbers
get larger the variance gets larger
reasonable choice for counting things
that don't have an upper bound like a
binomial does okay so we're going to
have two poissons here
home score and Away score or your score
and your opponent's score right so two
poisson means and then the means in turn
will be determined by
a log linear equation the reason it's
going to be log linear is because the
poisson mean has to be positive
and the way to constrain that is to make
it inverse log inverse log right so
exponential
of that and so there'll be two pieces
Alpha and Delta uh attack and defense
which is why I chose those those they
attack so for the away team it'll be the
uh the alpha
uh
uh I think I have that backwards it
should be the alpha yeah it should be
the alpha of of the away team and the
Delta the defense of the home team oh no
sorry this backwards this is the home
sorry home is going to be the alpha of
the home team and the defense of the
away team and then Ada is a a factor for
home home field advantage right you play
better at home because all the fans are
yelling for you and you sleep in your
own bed at night and stuff like that uh
so some some unknown factor all right
and then for the uh but we're going to
do is transform those so that they're
centered on the mean so that centered on
the kind of like we did for the baseball
we Center out on the mean so this is
going to be the mean score of a rugby
match and then these are the so that
they all add up to zero these are going
to be transformed so they're a little
easier to interpret
okay oh and then for the away team it's
exactly the same but there's no Ada
right and then uh the alphas and Deltas
are reversed so it's the alpha of the
away team and the Delta of the home team
I hope that's clear
well they can't be both oh I see yeah
then you yeah you could do it right you
just leave the Ada off of both of them
if they're playing like in the United
States or something right
I don't think that happens in Six
Nations though so we don't have to worry
about it
all right
I'm just going to explain this uh it's
just a pandas factorized as my favorite
pandas function it essentially does what
scikit learns label encoder does so it
takes a list of team names here
and it turns them into integers from
zero to the number of teams so it's
gonna
it's going to turn it into zero through
five in this case right
and uh so one of the newer features of
Pi MC it's actually not a prime C4 thing
it was available in later versions of
prime C3 is that you can uh specify the
size of your variables in your model
using labeled arrays rather than just
integers so I'm going to take my list of
teams and use them as the coordinates
and then when I print out the results
and whatever it will have the name of
you know England Wales Etc on them and
so I put that in a dictionary and I pass
that to the model as the chords argument
all right and another thing that I'm
going to do that's relatively new in pi
MC is I'm going to make my data mutable
what does that mean mutable means I can
change my data why would I want to
change my data well I'll fit my model
using you know as we do in machine
learning we fit them all using fitting
data and then I want to use this model
right I want to say okay now that I fit
my model I want to see what Wales and
England do next week when they play in
Wales and so I'll I'll change the data
and then without having to rerun the
model it'll it'll generate predictions
for me right so I have this thing called
mutable data so I'm going to change the
home and away teams later on
so what it's really doing is adding it
as a node in the graph as a symbolic
note and then when it's symbolic I can
feed whatever values that I want into
them
okay
so next step priors what are my priors
going to be they're all going to be
normal right we're dealing with uh rates
uh sorry
um not rates but actually factors that
have been transformed to the real line
so my home field advantage Ada is just
going to be a normal with mu 1 Sigma 1.
those seem small but this is on the logs
or inverse log scale so they get blown
up when you call exponential on them so
that's actually quite diffuse and then
mu uh so you know exponential of three
is about 17 or 20 or something like that
and so that's a reasonable approximate
mean for what a population an average
score is going to be and then uh alphas
and deltas and now notice I I didn't
call shape now I call dims and I just
passed the list of the dictionary of
teams to that and so it'll make sure
that it's got one for each team on
attack and defense
go ahead
um it shouldn't really be science it
should be Pro it should be whatever so
you could give them uninformative priors
there's a thing in here called a flat
prior that's just
no in no District it's not even a real
distribution
um you really want to add as much domain
expertise as you can the only domain I
don't know anything about rugby I work
in baseball so only information I know
is what the scores kind of tend to be
like you can't get scores of a million
and you can't they don't tend to be like
one or zero so I I actually just peaked
at the population and put the population
mean in here and that's a valid thing to
do here because one way of thinking
about your prior is actually the
underlying population that you're trying
to infer
right like that baseball player right I
used kind of the population of all
baseball players that's a great prior
because you know what that is you don't
know where your player is in that but
mine has got to be in there somewhere or
most likely you want to allow for it to
possibly be the greatest baseball player
ever but that's not likely to be the
case unless there's lots of data to
support it yeah
oh what do I do here
variable name Ada already exists well no
it doesn't
oh I hit it twice didn't I
must have hit it twice all right
okay deterministic so here's my
transformation so a t dot mean that's
asara tensor so you try to use asara
functions here when you can it's got
most of what numpy has all the important
ones anyway so there's Alpha star and
Delta star and then my model for home
and away just like I wrote above mu plus
ETA plus Alpha plus Delta for home same
for away except no ETA
likelihoods remember the only difference
here is we have observed and so we're
passing Rugby data home score the first
one rugby data away score for the second
one
and
um I always like to strip out the panda
stuff and use the values in principle it
works with pandas but sometimes I get
unexpected things going on
and again we're going to look at our
model again
and it's bigger it's more complex now
even this simple model and just for
convenience I'm going to wrap this all
the whole model in a function so I can
just create a new model whenever I need
to because I'm going to intentionally do
bad things with this model
um sorry the colors are so bad here hold
on
I'm going to go back to my
is that easier to see
uh so remember I ran sample with no
arguments before and everybody freaked
out uh because there's a whole bunch of
defaults here and they're usually
reasonable but it's always good to know
what you can change and there's even
more than this but these are the ones
you change more often right so you want
to know how many draws do you need
thousands of good that's how many draws
after the model's finished tuning
usually only for hamiltonian Monte Carlo
usually a thousand or so is good enough
assuming the model is converged tuning
for small models thousands also pretty
good I like to do two by default
whatever
um
you we'll we'll see in a minute
how you know whether you need more or
not
um
a lot of these things get Auto assigned
so the step means the mcmc algorithm the
step method the way and so it knows how
to do a step of a particular algorithm
it'll assign them automatically unless
you want to override it I'll show you
how to do that in just a second
especially specify initial values if you
want to how many chains you want to you
want to sample from all of these things
I'll go through some of these here in a
second
so assigning a sampling algorithm
usually you want to let it do this
itself unless you have a good reason to
override it but you can so I can
instantiate a metropolis algorithm and
pass it and it'll do Metropolis sampling
but we saw that Metropolis algorithm
isn't very good so you wouldn't want to
do this most of the time
the only way that so underneath under
the hood the um every distributions has
a uh a competence Associated or every
algorithm has a competence associated
with it that says I'm good at continuous
variables I'm good at discrete variables
don't use me here things like that and
so it goes through when it auto assigns
and determines the best the ones with
the highest competence score and assigns
it so in general continuous variables
get the nut sampler
but those variables have to be
continuous right because it uses
gradient information you can't take
gradients of discrete things so if it's
discrete you get Metropolis sorry
and then a binary gets a binary
Metropolis where you can only assign
zeros and ones
okay that's generally it but there are
other Samplers that are available to you
initial values you can pass your own
otherwise it will use the mean or the
mode or the median depending on which
distribution you can sample to get it
again most of the time here unless you
have a tricky model that it can be
helpful to specify an initial value you
can override it by passing them here so
let's do a simple
thing here 500 draws with no tuning
using Metropolis with an initializing
Ada to be negative one
and I'm just doing this
oh God
any questions while it's sampling this
really simple model for a short period
of time yes
to monitor the data
update the model with new data
oh yeah well you can predict with the
model with new data
but if you've got new data that you want
to use to fit the model you've got to
refit it I mean if you want to be a
really awesome Bayesian you really want
to like take your posteriors from the
last one and use it in the prior but
that's harder to do than you think right
because you'll get a sometimes a weird
posterior distribution and how do you
turn that into a prior if it's done a
good job all your posteriors are going
to be multivariate normal and you could
just make them multivariate normal so
you could do that but you kind of
manually have to do that
all right it finished finally
um
actually it only took one set so it's
having a problem compiling I guess for
some reason
okay
and if we look at Ada here it doesn't
look very good so this is a trace plot
from RVs that's those are supposed to be
histograms over there they don't look
very good and then this is the trace so
this is the sequence of 500 values and I
didn't do any tuning on here and I used
a crappy algorithm so this is what we
expect right so they all started at
negative one and they popped up but
they're not really in the same region
and there's four chains here so there's
four different lines so it doesn't look
very good
all right let's do it for real now
and hopefully this doesn't take very
long
so I'm going to do this is really the
defaults I could have just called sample
without any arguments here
um
here we go so it's Auto signing blah
blah blah
yeah this is a bad demo sorry it usually
runs a lot faster
I'm gonna I'm gonna run everything below
here just to speed things up
okay and look oh you got some warnings
here the acceptance probability does not
match the target blah blah blah there
are five divergences after tuning blah
blah blah okay we'll see what those are
later so we try to warn you when things
go wrong uh as best we can
pardon me
uh should be close to 0.8 and it's not
so it's supposed to be 0.8 yeah
don't worry I'll get back I'll get to it
but here we see estimates
of alpha this is the attacking strength
and so England's the best
as they are at everything all right so
and and so there are four chains and
they all look the same which should
Inspire confidence right they all
started and they all ended up at the
same place in in each of these so they
look pretty good
the countries are where we expect them
to be and then defense so it's flipped
around now so Italy's the worst and now
Ireland's the best
so these comport to um what we expect
mu and Ada so this is a posterior plot
so this gives you
a
HDI which is a probability interval so
there's a 94 probability the two values
between those two points and then its
distribution so 8 is 0.24 mu is 2.8
remember these are on the log scale so
if we convert these 2.8 is about 16
points 2.8 plus 2.24 is about
21 points so as a home field advantage
of four and a half points which
I guess is reasonable in American
football it's like three points I think
for home field most of the time and it
probably varies by country too right
depending on where you are
um
these samples are stored used in a
modified X-ray back end so labeled
arrays which is pretty nice and that's a
class inside of the RVs package again so
you can see our posterior distribution
has you know for each chain all of the
draws for each of the teams they're
labeled with names so they're really
easy to use
um so you got your posterior in there
your log likelihood sample stats for
things like well we'll look at what some
of these are in a second
and even a copy of the data in here so
inference data is one of the relatively
recent Innovations of Pi MC that makes
things a lot easier
parallel sampling you really want to do
more than one chain for one thing you've
you know all our computers here have
probably at least four cores if not
eight and you can you know it's this is
all embarrassingly parallel Every Chain
can be sampled independently of one
another
so there's no reason not to so by
default it takes the half of the number
of cores you have available uh so I got
four automatically without telling it
anything in this example I I picked six
chains and using four cores so it did it
you know
partially parallel and so you end up
with you know n times C chains here so
this was for Alpha so there's six of
them so it's six by one hundred by six
is the size
and you you know you typically want to
combine all of these together at the end
so kind of the last topic we have about
15 minutes left
um is an important piece we referred to
it earlier on model checking is very
important uh you don't you can get
reasonable looking results and it just
could be complete nonsense and it's hard
to tell sometimes whether it is there's
two components to model checking
convergence diagnostics at least for
mcmc did mcmc actually work right mcmc
can work and your model may or may not
be good but you at least want to make
sure mcmc Works before you proceed and
given that mcmc worked okay
what is the fit of the model like how
does it does it make any sense does it
correspond to what the data suggests all
of those things
so how do we do this stuff convergence
Diagnostics the easiest thing is to gaze
at the trace just look at it
that's what a trace looks like so this
is one run I call this bad Trace because
I did bad things with it
uh what did I do I only tuned it for 10
iterations which was not very good and
you can see you know this is for Two
Chains they don't they don't correspond
very well you know this kind of gets
stuck in places from time to time so it
needs to be tuned a little bit more a
tune tune one you want to look for this
sort of fuzzy caterpillar kind of thing
going on over here right they remember
what we needed what we're trying to look
for Here a stationary uh homogeneous
Markov chain means it's not you know the
chain isn't moving around the mean is
staying relatively constant the variance
is staying relatively constant that sort
of thing this is getting a little closer
but it's not even quite there yet
remember we saw a warning about
divergences in fact this is exactly the
warning I pasted it down here there were
five divergences after tuning increased
Target accept or re-parametrize we try
to suggest what to do to resolve
problems where we can a Divergence is
when this Hamilton member hamiltonian
Monte Carlo was doing the LeapFrog steps
and then sampling LeapFrog steps and
LeapFrog steps we're trying to trace
this continuous hamiltonian system as
best it can well sometimes it does a
poor job of it so here are a couple
where it's done a good job so the true
distribution here is the this cone of
red and yellow and so here it's
wandering around nicely there it's not
doing too bad and this one it got
launched into space over here and it
diverts way off in a low probability
region that would be a Divergence you
don't need to freak out if this happens
unless it happens a lot so we only had
five in this case over a thousand
samples I wouldn't worry about that
um
uh setting a higher Target acceptance is
one way of resolving this and so what
that will do it will increase the number
of baby steps that it has to take and so
um so that the acceptance rate so 0.8 is
the default it's a relatively good
default if you're having trouble boost
it to 0.9 or 0.95 or 0.99 even it'll
take longer to run but you'll you'll get
fewer divergences even better
re-parametrize your model it's sometimes
a sign that your model is a little bit
wonky so um and there I won't go into
what that means here but
reparametrization often works too
um with these um
gradient based Samplers there's some
information that you can get from those
because of the energy remember we're
tracking
energy here momentum and so forth and
based on on the estimates of the energy
at each step relative to the overall
energy of the sampling you can estimate
how well
the algorithm has been been exploring
the posterior distribution and it's
based on this notion of a Bayesian
fraction of missing information that
again I will
gloss over a little bit you want it to
be close to one and so
I don't know those look close to one to
me there's no real good cut off but the
easiest way to deal with this is to do
an energy plot so this plots the the
transition energy transitions at each
step versus the overall marginal energy
after fitting and you want them to sort
of overlap like they do here
bad ones look like that
where the marginal energy distribution
is way wider and so it's saying that the
transition energy just isn't covering
everything okay so that's a bad sign I
sometimes get like bimodal ones where
there's two blue bumps on either side
that's a bad sign too
uh one other that's worth noting is
something called used to be the called
the Gelman Reuben statistic now it's
called our hat or the potential scale
reduction this is essentially an
analysis of variants of the traces if
you know it and then an analysis of
variances it's comparing the variation
within a particular chain to the
variance between chains and if they're
the same they should be similar to one
another if the your chains are in
different spots the between variance is
wider than the within right so it's kind
of what an anova does
um and those should also be and so it's
so as
um
it converges on the overall variance the
r hat will get close to one so all you
have to know is you want your R Heights
close to one so if you call RVs dot
summary you get a nice summary table
and your our hats will be over here and
look they're all really close to one so
we're happy about these so convergence
Diagnostics done
we've got a yes
the burn in yeah two we call it
apparently we're not supposed to call it
burn in anymore we're supposed to call
it tuning so it's tuning for a tune for
a thousand
and that's again I usually pick 2 000
except for a really simple model back in
the bad days of metropolis you'd do like
a hundred thousand so it's it's much
better now
but you'll know if you need more you'll
you'll have signs of lack of convergence
yeah in some cases you just need to run
it longer that's that's all
so goodness of fit last topic
goodness of fit um you wanna you wanna
this is essentially a calibration check
for your model
and um
the best way to do this sort of thing is
to compare
the output from your model to the data
that was used to fit the model
and really you're
if you draw a whole bunch of samples
from your model your data should just
look like another draw from that model
otherwise you can't really claim that
this is the data generating model which
is what you want the nice thing is is
that Bayes gives you an automatic way of
doing this and this is called the
posterior predictive distribution and
this is it here so F of theta given Y is
just our posterior remember
and then
P of Y tilde given Theta P tilde are new
values
right things were going to sample from
the data given Theta and that Theta has
already been conditioned on y
um this is the predictive distribution
this is just our likelihood we're
drawing values from our likelihood
remember logical likelihood is y given
Theta as well
so we're including the residual
uncertainty in our parameters and the
stochastic sampling uncertainty of just
you know drawing from a binomial
distribution and then you integrate over
Theta which sounds intimidating because
integration is hard but you get this for
free already because you fit your model
using mcmc so we don't have to worry
about it so we can get this all we have
to do is sample from our after fitting
our data or our model sample from our
likelihoods and so we have a method for
doing that in pi C it's called sample
posterior predictive
and it's gonna this argument here will
just stick it back onto the trace
um sorry for the functional programmers
out there but it's just gonna add it to
that Trace silently without telling you
and so we'll have a thing in here called
posterior predictive now
and we can do plots so there's RVs has
plot PPC and these are cumulative
distributions of draws from the model
which are blue and their mean is a
dashed yellow line and the data is a
black line which is kind of hard to see
here but
but that's a good sign too right if you
can't even see your data that's a good
sign if it was out here I'm going over
here we'd be worried right so these are
good
checks The observed data looks like
draws from the posterior distribution
oh got 10 minutes left I lied I had one
more topic making predictions
because I mentioned this before right
I can swap out swap in new data so now
that I've fit my model I want to know
when Wales comes to visit England who's
going to win
uh and I can do that so P so I open my
model again just as if I was going to
add more variables to it except now I
call set data and then I I set
um all I'm doing all I'm adding here are
indices I'm pulling out the index
corresponding to England and Wales
adding one to home team one to away team
and then I call sample posterior
predictive
and then I pull out the values
and those are posterior predictive
distributions of scores
of England playing Wales
presumably at Wembley or something right
so England's going to win apparently
and and and what you can do is pairwise
subtract or not subtract but um do the
you know calculate a Boolean for when
the home is greater than the away and
take their mean and so this implies an
82 percent probability of England
winning
but this is my it's kind of a dumb
simple model the one that's on our
website uses a hierarchical model I
don't think that will help this here we
should probably change that that only
helps when you have imbalanced data sets
really but the idea is the same you can
build a way more complex model than this
right Theta could be more nuanced than
that it could have more information
about the teams it could have we could
use better historical information
somehow waiting more recent events stuff
like that so you can always make more
and in fact I was doing like an
individual based one here for like the
pitching model right where you had
different pitchers
um because every pitcher is going to
respond to the sticky stuff incident
differently like this guy might have
been cheating here
um that sort of thing so you can always
build more complex models but that
wasn't kind of the point here
um you want to learn more there's more
here including a brand new course from
uh Pine C Labs
Thomas Vicki's company they've got a
course called intuitive Bays where you
can learn a little bit more about all
this stuff so if you're interested track
Thomas down
um he looks like that guy back there
anyway uh I have uh five minutes left I
think so
um a couple questions
do bookmakers use Pi MC I know one that
does but I'm not allowed to gamble on
Sports because I work in for Major
League Baseball so
yeah
do they use Bayesian methods probably a
lot of them probably use machine
learning I would imagine but um I'm
guessing I only know one that I know for
sure does but
um I would imagine that you would think
this would be a good approach for those
sorts of problems yeah and the sorry the
question was do bookmakers use Pi MC and
I I know at least one that does
any other questions yeah
uh the question was if you have
different Samplers for different
variables how does that work do you do
them at the same time or sequentially uh
Pine c will will uh so HMC happens all
at once you walk over the entire
multi-dimensional space
um if I had a discrete variable in there
I would have a mixture of metropolis and
HMC and it would do one than the other
I'm not sure what which order it would
do it so it would condition on one and
it gets very sketchy when you do these
mixed ones I don't think there's been a
lot of research into what that does to
the convergence because the it'll change
the geometry when you kind of modify the
model outside of the HMC
but sometimes it works I've done it a
few times and I've gotten good results
so from a pragmatic sense it seems to
work I would imagine if you had a lot of
discrete variables it would be harder
but usually it's like one variable that
has to be discrete and so and it tends
to work so but that's just based on my
experience
uh maybe two more yes one at the back
yeah it wouldn't be a strength
it wouldn't be a strength of this I
would see how it goes if there was a lot
of data for example
but yeah you might then look at tree
based models or something yeah yeah one
more question yeah
a cluster of CPUs not out of the box it
uses gpus now under Jax Thomas can you
answer that about clusters
schedule
so the answer was version 4.1 will help
you more with that yeah all right I
think we're done so but feel free to
talk to Thomas or I
um sometime during the conference hope
to see you out there thanks a lot
[Applause]